my genuine feeling was I think for a
very long time internally I'm a broken
toy inner voice depression fill in the
blank these are just flaws that are
to be lived with because they cannot be
fixed therefore let me focus on some
things I can control
and there is a half truth in there which
is focus on the things that you can
change don't focus on the things you
have no power over
but there's a very debilitating
assumption in there which is I cannot
change in a meaningful way my interior
experience and I'm very happy to say
that that has proven incorrect there are
things you can do
I would also say that
no one bullet is a Panacea
you would never say all right I did this
amazing workout and I'm done I am fit
forever that's just not how it works